welcome back to las vegas now up next
i'm going to introduce you to a unique
choice for a holiday gift that is not
only practical but
it also helps keep you safe from covid
i'm talking about fisher's space pins so
check it out
when kobit had actually first hit we
first had to look at our products and
see
what types of value propositions do we
have for our consumer that are
beneficial during these times
and our raw brass base pens are actually
made of 85 copper and 15
zinc it's a copper alloy that was
registered by the epa's being
anti-microbial
and this is a fantastic product for the
gift time of the year we all want our
loved ones to be kept safe during these
times and so
this has become a top seller for fisher
space been since covet has
been upon us we also had to look at what
types of functionality differences do we
have for doctors
and medical companies as well too and
our ag7 the original astronaut pen and
our shuttle pen
is actually autoclavable meaning they
can go through the sterilization process
with extreme pressure and steam to
sterilize the pen itself
firefighters law enforcement search and
rescue game wardens conservation
specialists
emts these are people that are on the
front lines every day
and so our first responder thin line
series at penn really was meant to honor
them and each one of these pens were
able to give back to a charity
that supports those communities as well
so i don't know about for you but for my
family as well we all have first
responders and frontline workers that
are working tirelessly right now during
this pandemic
what a better way to honor them to get
them a tool for their trade
that also gives back to the community
that supports them itself so
these have been extremely popular since
covet has hit for us
but right now during this time of the
year it's a great holiday gift
opportunity
and you can go to spacepen.com and learn
more about the charities we support
through those first responder thinline
series
and also feeding america's coven 19
relief fund as well too with the
antimicrobial raw brass
over the course of 72 years of being in
business we had not actually sold
ourselves
an actual bullet pen or any pen for that
matter with the nasa logo on it
so for the first time that we've been a
partner of massive for the last 50 years
we now
offer a series of pens that are
dedicated with the nasa meatball logo
and the moment we sent these out some of
our fans that have been begging for
decades through newsletters and emails
wrote and said finally we're so glad to
be able to get these from space pen
and then not to mention the fact
recently that space force just had its
first group of enlistees just enlist in
space force
and we were in contact with space force
itself and they said what what better
way to sign your enlistment papers than
with a space
pen and we agreed and so this series of
pen right here honors our new branch of
the military
which is underneath the air force and
that is space force and again
you know on the space side space is
exciting today you know all the new
accomplishments between spacex and nasa
and
seeing commercial partnerships really
evolve in this business has made space
exciting you can go to spacepen.com
take a look at any of these models and
more on our website or if you'd like to
come in person
you can come to boulder city nevada
we're at 711 yucca street
and we do have a pretty strict covent
policy so make sure you have a mask with
you we only allow one person in the
store at a time so you'll have to bring
your patients along with you as well
and give us the ability to clean and
sterilize before the next customer comes
in
for more information fisher space pen
company is located on yucca street in
boulder city
give them a call that number is right
there on your screen or just simply find
them at spacepin.com